BREAKING NEWS FROM THE SUEZ
CANAL.
THE SHIP IS FREE ON THE
EVERGREEN.
IT WAS ONE OF THE LARGEST SHIPS
TO SAIL THE SEAS ON THE MUDDY
BANKS OF THE SUEZ CANAL.
EARLIER, WORKERS MANAGED TO
DISLAKE GEORGE THE STERN.
THE SHIP HAD BEEN STOPPED ROCK
SOLID IN THE MUD FOR NEARLY A
WEEK.
FREEING UP THE CANAL FOR
SHIPPING TRAFFIC CANNOT COME
SOON ENOUGH.
BUSINESSES AROUND THE WORLD WERE
ALREADY FEELING THE PANDEMIC.
THE SHIPPING SLOWDOWN WAS THE
LAST THING THAT THEY NEEDED.
MORE THAN 350 VESSELS HAVE BEEN
WAITING TO USE THE CANAL.
VISITORS ARE TAKING THE LONG WAY
AROUND AFRICA.
SOON IT COULD BE MONTHS TO
REPAIR THE DAMAGE TO THE GLOBAL
SUPPLY CHAIN, CNN'S BEN WEDEMAN
IS IN CAIRO. DEFTEROUS IS THERE.
>> Reporter: FINALLY THEY
SUCCEEDED SINCE LAST TUESDAY IN
FREEING THE SPIRE SHIP, BRINGING
IT BACK TOO THE MIDDLE OF THAT
STRETCH OF THE SUEZ CANAL AND IT
IS NOW ON ITS WAY NORTH TO THE
GREAT BITTER LAKE WHERE WE HEARD
FROM OSAMA ROBIA, THE CHAIRMAN
OF THE SUEZ CANAL AUTHORITY.
IT WOULD GO TO BE CHECKED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE SHIP IS STILL
SEAWORTHY AFTER THIS TRAUMATIC
EXPERIENCE, BUT, REALLY, IT
START FAREED THE EARLY HOURS OF
TODAY, MONDAY.
IT WAS A ROLLER COASTER OF HOPES
AND EXPECTATIONS, JUST BEFORE
SUNRISE.
THE NEWS CAME OUT THAT THE
DREDGING OPERATION ALONG WITH
TUGBOATS WAS ABLE TO FREE THE
STERN OF THE SHIP AND LARGELY
MOVE IT OUT OF SORT OF ITS
BLOCKING POSITION IN THE CANAL.
BUT THERE WERE POINTS DURING THE
DAY WHEN IT APPEARED STRONG
WINDS PUSHED IT BACK, BLOCKING
THE CANAL AGAIN.
BUT NOW, FORTUNATELY, THE CANAL
IS OPENED, ACCORDING TO CHAIRMAN
OF THE SUEZ CANAL AUTHORITY,
NAVIGATION HAS RESUMED IN THE
CANAL.
AND THERE HAVE BEEN
CELEBRATIONS.
THE SHIPS IN THE CANAL BLOWING
THEIR HORNS.
I'D LIKE TO SAY THE HORNS BEHIND
ME IN CAIRO ARE BLOWING IN
CELEBRATION AS WELL.
BUT I THINK THEY'RE JUST BLOWING
THEIR HORNS.
BUT I IMAGINE MOST EGYPTIANS AT
THIS MOMENT ARE SAYING, GOOD
RIDDANCE TO THE EVERGIVEN.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
BEN IS IN CAIRO.
JD, YOU HAVE BEEN LOOKING AT THE
GLOBAL BUSINESS IMPLICATIONS OF
WHAT HAS SEEN THIS
SKYSCRAPER-SIZE SHIP, WHICH IS
NOW A WRENCH AWAY FROM THE
CANAL'S BANK, IT IS BEING TOWED
AWAY AS BEN SUGGESTED.
JUST WHAT SORT OF DISRUPTION HAS
THIS CAUSED?
>> Reporter: WELL, I TELL YOU,
THIS IS A PARKING LOT OF VESSEL,
STILL, PECKY.
SO YOU HAVE TO THINK ABOUT
TRYING TO UNWIND THESE BACKLOG
THAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW.
SO WE PEAK AT ALMOST 370 SHIPS
AND THE VOLUME THERE THAT WE
HAVE IN THE CANAL IN A NORMAL
DAY IS ABOUT 50.
NOW, THIS IS GOING TO BE
INTERESTING TO SEE HOW MUCH THEY
CAN ACCELERATE.
THE EGYPTIAN GOVERNMENT SAID,
PRESIDENT ASSISI ACCELERATED,
MAXIMUM CAPACITY ACCORDING TO
GEORGE'S LIST IS 80-TO-90
VESSELS A DAY.
YOU HAVE TO REV UP, GET THEM IN
POSITION AND MAKE SURE SAFETY
PRECAUTIONS ARE TAKEN HERE.
THE BEST CASE, FIVE-TO-SIX DAYS
TO CLEAR THE BACKLOG OF SHIPS
WAITING THERE ALREADY.
HE WAS SAYING SIX DAYS.
THE LARGEST SHIPPING COMPANY IN
THE WORLD.
WE HAVE AT LEAST TEN VESSELS
HAVE HAVE LIVESTOCK.
WE HEARD A LOT ABOUT THE CATTLE
EARLY ON.
WE ARE EAGER TO HEAR THAT.
MAYBE 370 OVERALL, 10% CARRYING
OIL AND GAS, PETRO CHEMICALS.
VERY CRITICAL SUPPLIES NEED TO
GO INTO LEBANON IN SYRIA, PAUSE
THEY'RE SHORT OF FUEL.
THE ECONOMIES ARE IN CRISIS
RIGHT NOW.
TO YOUR POINT ON THE SUPPLY
CHAIN, WE HAVE AUTO PARTS,
TEXTILE, FOOD STUFF ALL LOCKED
UP AT THIS STAGE.
NORMALLY WE HAVE $10 A DAY AFTER
THE VALUE, $400 MILLION AN HOUR.
THAT HAS STALLED.
IN EFFECT, WE HAD DOZENS OF
SHIPS THAT SAID WE WILL GO TO
THE CAPE OF GOOD HOPE.
TO THE SOUTHERN TIP OF AMERICA,
INTO EUROPE AND THE UNITED
STATES, BECAUSE THEY LOST HOPE
AND PATIENCE RIGHT NOW.
SO THERE IS A COMPETENCE ISSUE,
OF COURSE, FOR THE SUEZ CANAL
BEFORE AND NOW AGAIN AFTER THIS.
CAN YOU DELIVER ON ALL THE
DEMAND OF THIS KEY ARTERY GOING
FORWARD IS A CRUCIAL QUESTION
THAT WE HAVE TODAY.
BUT THINK ABOUT THE OPTION HERE,
BECK WHY I, IF YOU DIDN'T UNLOCK
IT AND GET IT MOVING, YOU WILL
HAVE TO HAVE A CRANE TRY TO
UNLOAD THOSE CONTAINERS AND PUT
THEM IN EVEN ANOTHER SHIP OR ON
THE SIDE, IT WOULD HAVE TAKEN
DAY, IF NOT WEEKS, TO DO IT.
SO THE GLOBAL COMMUNITY TONIGHT
SAYS, SHEESH, WHAT A RELIEF.
THAT'S THE ANSWER.
>> YEAH.
ABSOLUTELY.
AND, BEN, THOSE WHO SAY THIS HAS
BEEN THE BIGGEST CRISIS IN THE
CANAL SINCE THE 1956 --
ALLUDING, OF COURSE, TO THE SUEZ
CRISIS.
AND IT IS KNOWN.
THE EGYPTIANS WILL NOT WANT
ANOTHER CRISIS IN THIS ARTERY OF
LIFE ANY TIME SOON, WILL IT?
>> Reporter: NO, OF COURSE, NOT.
WE DID SEE BETWEEN 2014 AND
2015, EGYPT AT THE INSPIRATION
OF A PRESIDENT ASSISSI SPENT $8
BILLION TO CREATE AN EXTRA LANE
TO THE SUEZ CANAL, TO FACILITATE
FURTHER PASSAGE OF SHIPS, BUT
THEY DIDN'T DO IT IN THAT
PARTICULAR AREA.
AND, OF COURSE, THE EGYPTIAN
GOVERNMENT PROMISED EGYPTIANS
THAT THERE WOULD BE REAL
DIVIDENDS IN TERMS OF ECONOMIC
RETURNS FROM THAT MASSIVE
PROJECT AND THEY HAVEN'T REALLY
MATERIALIZED.
AND, OF COURSE, ONE OF THE
LONG-TERM WORRIES REGARDING THE
SUEZ CANAL IS THAT OTHER OPTIONS
ARE COMING UP.
THE CHINESE BELT AND ROAD
PROJECTS, THE REPORT OF
PIPELINES FROM THE GULF TO
ISRAEL, TALK ABOUT OPENING UP
ARCTIC ROUTES BETWEEN ASIA AND
EUROPE.
AND SO THE SUEZ CANAL, A PART OF
THE REASON WHY IT WAS EXPANDED
WAS IN ANTICIPATION OF THESE
SORT OF PROJECTS, BUT, YES, THE
SUEZ CANAL OPENED IN 1869 WITH A
LOT OF PROMISE, BUT IT WAS
CLOSED FOR EIGHT MONTHS BETWEEN
1956 AND '57, AFTER THE '56 WAR,
IT WAS CLOSED FROM 1967 TO 1975
BECAUSE OF OTHER HOSTILITIES
BETWEEN ISRAEL AND ITS ARAB
NEIGHBORS.
SO IT'S HAD A ROCKY HISTORY AND
IT HASN'T EVER REALLY LIVED UP
TO THE PROMISE THAT THE MAN WHO
CAME UP WITH THE IDEA OF THE
SUEZ CANAL HAD DREAMED OF, IT
WAS NEVER REALLY REALIZED.
CERTAINLY, THIS INCIDENT OF THE
PAST WEEK UNDERSCORES THE
VULNERABILITIES OF THE SUEZ
CANAL.
HAVING SAID THAT, WE HAVE SEEN
AN INCREDIBLE EFFORT BY THE
EGYPTIANS ANDER THAT PARTNERS,
THE DUTCH AND THE JAPANESE AND
OTHERS TO FINALLY GET THIS CANAL
UP AND RUNNING AGAIN.
>> ABSO